18:05 in the austrian army is on the
march against napoleon hit inca great
the man leading this army was francis a
second the holy roman emperor he was
also the emperor of austria are tightly
created in response to Napoleon
declaring himself the Emperor of France
because he wasn't about to be our
tempered by anyone so as far as empires
go the austrian empire was fairly
run-of-the-mill the holy roman empire
however was not so normal it was
comprised of hundreds of mostly
german-speaking states who swore
allegiance to an emperor the most
powerful state in the Holy Roman Empire
was Austria followed by Prussia and both
of these had territory inside and
outside of the Empire because it was
complicated having been defeated by
Napoleon Frances gave up his title of
Holy Roman Emperor and the Holy Roman
Empire itself was dissolved in 1806 most
of its former states except notably
Prussia and Austria were brought into
the Confederation of the Rhine which was
a French puppet state the people that
lived in these states were somewhat
unhappy living under the dominance of
France and many quickly began to resent
everything French one way to counter
French influence was to emphasize just
how German they were so side note the
term German was used to refer to people
that spoke German there were Germans but
no Germany in some respects there was a
sense of shared identity and culture but
Germans were also very divided by
religion economics and politics so long
story short after Napoleon had been
defeated by the Russians Prussia and
Austria rose up against him and by 1815
he had been firmly defeated Austin
Napoleon's defeat the Congress of Vienna
was cool to establish a maintain a
balance of power so that no country
could become too powerful this balance
of power is known as the concert of
Europe
a man called clemens von metonic was
very important to the establishment of
this new order metonic was an Austrian
diplomat who was instrumental in
protecting Austria from Napoleon's
harsher punishments as a result of the
Congress pressure gained this territory
most notably the Rhineland an Austria
gained this territory in Italy but lost
the Austrian Netherlands importantly the
German Confederation was formed it was
led by a president who was also the
Emperor of Austria had these borders
which included some of Prussia and
Austria but not all of Prussia in
Austria but was also totally not the
Holy Roman Empire under a different name
the German Confederation was quite a
loose alliance and as such was seen as
quite weak in comparison to other powers
such as France and Russia this led to
some calls for political unification
which would help protect the smaller
German states and prevent a repeat of
Napoleon Prussia was keen on the idea of
German
unification because it being the largest
German state would be in charge in 1819
Prussia formed the Toba rhyme which was
a customs and trading Union which sought
to make commerce between German states
easier this was not just an economic
Union Austria was excluded from joining
which meant that there was no economic
counterbalance to Prussia by 1848 the
sovereign looked like this throughout
the early nineteenth century liberal
ideas were spreading throughout the
continent and the new middle class
wanted reforms such as political
representation and freedom of speech in
Austria these coastal reform had been
repressed by metonic by censorship and
prosecution the cries for reform
continued to grown in 1848 riots broke
out across the German Confederation in
Austria in Austria the reforms were
short-lived but metalic was forced to
resign and fled to Britain rights in
Berlin was suppressed by Princeville
helm of Prussia via cannons which earned
him the nickname the Prince of grapeshot
so the king of prussia friedrich wilhelm
the fourth progressing Lee agreed to the
establishment of a parliament which
could advise him the liberal factions
involved in the rioting believed that
the best way to secure these reforms was
via a unified Germany as such liberals
across the German Confederation called
the Frankfurt Parliament which planned
to unify Germany declare Friedrich
Wilhelm the fourth as its Emperor he
said no and by late 18-49 the reform
movement had died down most of the
reforms implemented by the Frankfurt
Parliament were quickly abandoned but
the idea of a unified Germany persisted
there were two proposals for a unified
German state Klein Deutschland which
means small Germany and grow staunch
lands which means large Germany the
difference was that grosse Deutschland
included the german-speaking parts of
the Austrian Empire whereas Klein done
schlund did not this idea of a shared
ethnic cultural and linguistic heritage
or destination is an important part of
nationalism for more homogenous places
like Germany or Italy nationalism was a
uniting factor for ethnically diverse
empires such as Russia or Austria was a
destabilizing force for example in
Austria the Hungarians attempted to
break away in 1848 but this was
prevented due to intervention from the
Russians
the Austrians were opposed to a unified
Germany which they weren't in charge of
Austria wasn't the only opponent of a
unified Germany France and Russia were
quite nervous about the idea as well
Austria was able to rely on Russian
pressure to dissuade the Prussians from
pursuing client Deutschland and maintain
the German Confederation Russian support
for Austria ended in 1854 when Austria
refused to help Russia in the Crimean
War against Britain France and the
Ottoman Empire at
years later Austria was defeated by
France and Sardinia and thus lost this
territory in northern Italy whilst
Austria was weakening Prussia found
itself gaining strength Prussia was
rapidly industrializing had access to a
great amount of natural resources such
as coal and was a major producer of iron
the silver iron also allowed Prussia to
export these products in its economy
grew in strength so in 1861 Friedrich
Wilhelm died and was succeeded by his
brother Bill him the first the
aforementioned Prince of grapeshot the
next year he appointed a man called Otto
von Bismarck as the minister president
of Prussia Bismarck was a very gifted
statesman and firmly opposed to the
liberal forces in Prussia he sought to
unify the northern German States remove
Austria from the German Confederation
and strengthen the position and prestige
of the Prussian King one of the first
things that Bismarck did was to
modernize and increase the size of the
Prussian military in case his plans led
to war
they did the first for a cow in 1864
after Denmark had declared that both
schleswig and holstein were Danish
territory whole stein was in the German
Confederation and in retaliation Prussia
and Austria declared war on Denmark
which they quickly won so Prussia
received Schleswig in Austria received
Holstein Austria was unhappy with the
results of the war because the new
territories were part of the solver
Rhine and Austria needed to travel
through Prussian territory to get to its
own Bismarck knew that this arrangement
would lead to war with Austria and so
made sure that the other European
nations stayed out of it he made a
defensive pact with the newly unified
Kingdom of Italy on the condition that
Italy would gain Veneto from Austria he
was also supported for French and
Russian ambitions to keep them neutral
eventually Austria tried to resolve the
issue surrounding Holstein and Bismarck
accused the Austrians of treating them
like enemies Prussian troops occupied
whole Sun in June 1866 most of the
German Confederation back Austria and
war broke out shortly afterwards
fortunately for Prussia the Italians
mobilized on the Austrian border and
declared war five days later Prussia
quickly defeated Austria's northern
allies and Austria had lost the war
within two months one of the reasons for
this was that Prussian troops were armed
with a new type of rifle the needle gun
the Austrians fared much better against
the Italians but their losses against
Prussia led them to surrender in the end
Prussia gained all of this territory
which became the North German
Confederation with its own parliament
Austria also agreed to give up Veneto
but because they had generally
outperformed the Italians they gave it
to France instead who then gave it to
Italy because 19th century war was weird
so the rapid rise of Prussia was
something that the French had not
I painted in 1870 the German Prince
Leopold Vilhelm the first cousin was
offered the Spanish crown the French
Emperor Napoleon the third did not want
the North German Confederation to gain
Spain as an ally and demanded the
Vilhelm order his cousin not to take the
crown Vilhelm told the French he'll get
back to them and so sent a telegram to
Bismarck
Bismarck edited the telegram so it
sounded like Villa home rudely brushed
the French off and published it this
made the French look weak and silly so
they declared war so the French
declaring war made them the aggresses
and thus the Prussians were able to gain
the support of the southern German
states so to summarise the war the
French couldn't mobilize as many men the
French Emperor was captured the French
had another revolution because it was
the 19th century and so at this point
why not
the Germans pushed this far into French
territory and on the 18th of January
1871 at the Palace of Versailles the
German leaders declared the creation of
the German Empire vilhelm the first as
Emperor the French soon after
surrendered agreed to pay indemnities
and giving Germany the territory of
alsace-lorraine so one of the great
debates surrounding the German Empire as
to what extent it was unification or
simply Prussian dominance the smaller
German states felt that they were unable
to protect themselves from their larger
neighbors but in return for protection
found themselves dominated by Prussia
except for leech design which was fine
the dominance of Prussia is best seen
through what is known as the Coulter
camp the culture struggle so northern
Germany was mostly Protestant was the
south had a large Catholic population
the Catholic Church had immense
political Authority Bismarck wished to
remove its influence and strengthen the
central government Catholic Bishops were
arrested on mass and Catholic
institutions were sidelined but
ultimately a persevered a unified
Germany quickly became a great power
Bismarck negotiated analyzed with the
austro-hungarian Empire and managed to
secure some African colonies by calling
the Berlin conference with the other
European powers it experienced a
population boom alongside rapid
industrialization and urbanization and
also became a global center of science
vilhelm the first died in 1888 he was
replaced by Friedrich the third who died
99 days later and he was followed by
vilhelm the second vilhelm wanted to
assert his own independence and so
encouraged Bismarck to resign in 1890
unlike his predecessors wilhelm ii was
very hot-headed and prone to immediate
reaction he was also determined to
increase the prestige of germany he did
this by undertaking a major naval boot
up in the early 20th century this upset
Britain
Britain had previously kept itself out
of European affairs but a large German
Navy posed a threat to its naval
hegemony and could even threaten the
British mainland so in 1914 the Archduke
Franz Ferdinand was assassinated by a
Serbian nationalist in the established
series of alliances and counter
alliances plunged Europe into World War
one
long story short Germany was unable to
break the stalemate that formed its
allies collapsed in a British blockade
meant that a major food shortage
occurred war fatigue and hunger led many
to protest and eventually revolt revolt
became full-on revolution and vilhelm
abdicated on the 9th of November 1918 a
republic was declared which soon after
accepted the terms of the Treaty of
Versailles which ultimately led to the
conditions which precipitated the rise
of the Nazi Party in conclusion it's
hard to overstate the effect of German
unification the rise of Prussia ended
Austria's dominance over Central Europe
and ushered in the end of the balance of
power established at the end of the
Napoleonic Wars
the strength of the new German Empire
alongside its foreign policy paved the
way for World War one and the new world
which was left in its wake I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching